I'm tempted to say smart,
creative people have no particularly
different set of character traits than
the rest of us,
except for being smart and creative and
those being character traits.
And then on the other hand,
I wrote a biography of Richard Fineman
and a biography if Isaac Newton.
Now there are two great scientific
geniuses whose characters were in some
superficial ways,
completely different.
Isaac Newton was solitary,
antisocial,
I think unpleasant.
I'm bitter,
fought with his friends as much as with
his enemies.
Richard Fineman was gregarious,
funny,
a great dancer,
uh,
loved women.
Isaac Newton,
I believe,
never had sex.
Richard Fineman I believe had plenty.
Um,
so you can't generalize there.
On the other hand,
they were both,
as I tried to get in their heads,
understand their minds,
the,
the nature of their genius.
I sort of felt I was seeing things that
they had in common and,
and they were things that had to do with
aloneness.
Um,
Newton was much more obviously alone
than fineman,
but fineman didn't particularly work
well with others.
Uh,
he was known as a great teacher,
but he wasn't a great teacher.
I don't think one on one.
I think he was a great lecturer.
I think it was a great communicator.
But when it came time to make the great
discoveries of science,
he was alone in his head.
And now I'm talking to,
when I say he,
I mean both fineman and Newton.
And this applies also I think to the
geniuses,
um,
that I write about in the information.
Charles Babbage,
Alan Turing,
Ada Byron,
they all had the ability to concentrate
with a sort of intensity that is
hard for mortals like me to grasp a kind
of,
um,
passion,
passion for abstraction.
Uh,
that doesn't lend itself to
easy communication.
I don't think.